but you know you got a little crunch in
it a little spice cause you got jalapeno
but then you got your peppers and your
onions like they meet in the middle
you're like oh i like that hey y'all i
am tabitha brown and today what we
making some good old vegan raw tacos but
what you might ask honey some good old
pecans with a little bit of spice i
think you might like it i sure do so
your first step is we have to soak them
in a little bit of water and liquid
aminos and then you let the pecans sit
and soak for about three hours and then
go wash some clothes or something watch
the kids or do something pick up a
couple people i don't know what you need
to do but three hours
i chose this dish for several reasons
one i always know if you eat raw it's
very healthy for you but i also need
delicious so it's one in the same and
honey it don't get hot in the kitchen
you get it done real quick nothing on it
ain't hot you ain't sweating honey and
everything is good i was not always
vegan it's coming up on two years in
august but uh i started the vegan
journey because i was sick i was sick
for a year and seven months and i
decided to take a 30 day vegan challenge
and started feeling better and it
literally changed my life so it was my
decision like this is for me but i
always tell anybody do what feels right
for you okay but it's something you want
to try try honey try for 30 days it
won't hurt your honey it might actually
help you now the mango cause we need a
little sweetness with all the spice
right then if you want to this is for
you you slice the rest of that little
pieces off cut it diagonal and then
across like cubes now make sure when you
cutting the mango you don't go all the
way through because it's two skins the
mango and yours we don't want to cut
either one of them all right so just
right above the skin
okay let's be safe take the knife go
right under it honey look ain't it cute
very good you got cute little mango
cubes for your good old taco don't get
no better than that so i normally eat
this dish you know the summer time
because it's hot and you don't have to
cook anything it's great when you can
set it up everybody can come over and
it's like a little taco bowl right
everybody come over and fix their own
little lettuce wrap and you ain't got to
do them but just watch everybody like
y'all like that don't you i know i did
it i came up with it all by myself yeah
it's very good it's impressive but them
pecans it's the mind trick honey you be
like am i eating meat or am i eating a
pecan oh it's a pecan yeah with a little
mushroom no it's meat no it's a pecan
because it's vegan very good so my tips
if you are thinking about starting a
plant-based diet if you are curious
about it first and foremost don't be so
hard on yourself honey don't take it so
serious it's okay relax all right then
what are your favorite foods that you
like to eat figure out how to make those
so you don't go into the oh my god i
need it i miss it type of thing right if
you come up with some of your best
recipes non-vegan then make them vegan
it makes things so much easier there's
so many options out there now but i say
take it slow don't be hard on yourself
and enjoy it honey this just make you
feel like you are doing something good
in the world
honey take a good old bite
sometimes it's so good you got to look
at it
you did that mm-hmm i'll wait oh you're
not you ain't making it yet oh that's
all right go ahead at your leisure
you